ادى رئيس البرازيلي الجديد
الدستوريه ادي رئيس هذه البلاد
القسمه اليوم لبلاده لفتره جديده عقبه
سجنه لعام ونصف بسبب التهم الفساد واسقطت
لاحقا وقد فاز سيلفا في الانتخابات
الاخيره بفارق ضئيل على منافسه الرئيس
السابق
جيرمان والذي غاب عن مراسب التنصيب في
سابقه غير موهوده في البلاد لعدم اعترافه
بفوز غريبه
مشاهد الان هذه الصور المباشره التي
تقام فيها
يقام فيها احتفال التنصيب تنصيب سيلفا
رئيسا جديدا للبلاد
في العاصمه البرازيليه مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود اذن في هذه اللحظات التي يؤدي فيها
الرئيس القسم ما الذي ينتظر البلاد برايه
نعم جمال بالفعل قبل لحظات فقط انها
الرئيس البرازيليه لولا ده سيلفا الزعيم
اليساري الذي كان قد حكم البلاد بين عامي
2002 و 2010 لفتين رئاسيتين ادى اليمين
الدستوريه هذه المره عام 2022 بعد اثنا
عشر عاما على تركه السلطه رئيسا مره اخرى
ليه البلاد ولكن في احوال مختلفه في
انقسام حال تشهده الميلاد فاز همم بفارق
مليونير صوت فقط بينه وبين الرئيس
المنتهيه ولايته جرير سونار لي يحكم
البلاد في ظل هذا الانقسام رايك
عن حفله تنصيب
اليامينيه وهو الخصم الرئيسي للرئيس
الحالي لولا دا سيلفا كان همم قد حذر من
عدم قبوله النتائج في حال فاز الرئيس
الولا ده سيلفا ولكنه بكل
الاحوال لم يستطع ان يرفض النتائج ولكنه
رفض تهنئه الرئيس دا سيلفا وغادر البلاد
قبل يوم فقط من التنصيب وترك البلاد ليحكم
همم نائب الرئيس امتون موراو بدلا منه
خلال هذا اليوم الذي كان فيه ما يشبه
الفراغ في الرئاسه هذه الخطوه تعتبر خطوه
سابقه تاريخيه في البرازيل الراي الاخر
الذي يقوله ايضا المراقبون انه يخشى انه
في حال فقد الحصانه التي كان يملكها كرئيس
جمهوريه وقبل ذلك كنائب فدرالي ربما يواجه
اي نوع من انواع
المحاكمات او التهم التي تؤدي به ربما الى
السجن الاحتياطي اا ازاء هذه المحاكمات
وهو الذي همم دفعه للمغادره والخروج من
البلاد حتى قبل ان تنتهي اولايته بشكل
كامل
وان يفقد همم ما لديه من حصانه تمسع بها
على مدر 30 عاما كان فيها نائما ثم رايسا
لي الجمهوريه يذكر انه الرئيس الاول في
تاريخ البلاد الذي يترشح لفتره رئاسيه
ثانيه في البرازيل ويخسر هذه الانتخابات
اكبر جمهوريه في العاصمه البرازيليه شكرا
لك